de quel soutien Yves gany Prigogine
aurait-il pu bénéficier au sein de
l'armée russe selon le New York Times le
général Sergueï sorovic qui n'était au
courant de la volonté du chef de Wagner
d'entrer en rébellion celui que la
presse russe surnomme le général
armagueton a été nommé à la tête des
opérations en Ukraine en octobre 2022
par sergeho hugu avant que ce dernier ne
décide finalement de confier ce rôle à
Valérie guerracinov et de faire de
sorovikings son adjoint selon le journal
américain d'autres généraux de l'armée
russe pourrait avoir soutenu le projet
du patron de la milice paramilitaire
aucun autre média n'a pu pour le moment
corroborer ses révélations mais des
représentants américains informés par
les services du renseignement planche
aussi sur la question
pour comprendre les événements du 24
juin le rôle de l'armée russe est plus
que jamais scruté par les observateurs
que Prigogine le chef du groupe Wagner
n'aurait probablement pas marché vers
Moscou s'il n'avait pas pensé qu'il y
avait des partisans qui l'aidera que
c'est trop épuront monter cette
autoroute principale la N4 en direction
de Moscou avec si peu de résistance je
veux dire avec quelques tirs et
seulement quelques morts sa pose
question
quelques heures avant les révélations du
quotidien c'est le président biélorus
qui livre à une nouvelle information
j'ai dit à Poutine on peut buter
Prigogine aucun problème si ce n'est pas
au premier essai alors ce sera au second
mais je lui ai aussi dit ne faites pas
ça parce qu'à l'heure il n'y aura pas de
négociation selon Alexandre Loukachenko
le chef de Wagner est arrivé hier en
Biélorussie
conformément à l'accord ayant mis fin à
la rébellion